why didn't you call the police
because i knew how it looked
i hated this man i'd be a suspect you
could have called it an enormously yeah
i could i could have
but i didn't
i ran
i changed my name
i started a new life
and i haven't been cassie since
oh that's good that's a clip from a new
harlem cobin thriller on netflix that's
sure to get your attention the master of
suspense has brought his best-selling
book stay close to the small screen it
features hobbit star richard armitage
and comedian eddie izzard stay close
tells the story of four people whose
dark secrets resurfaced that could
change their lives forever harlan harlan
copen joins us right now good morning
harlan how are you doing
hey how's it going nate good morning how
are you guys good good morning we're
good we're glad to have you now our
morning is better thank you for the book
and thank you for joining us now i i
imagine when you're writing a book like
stay close you can visualize the
characters what was it like to actually
see them on the small screen
it's always completely different than
what i imagined but you know it's part
of the process i actually really loved
it you know seeing cush jumbo from the
good wife playing megan and the rest of
his guys bring it to life if you don't
get jazzed by that man you're in the
wrong business it's always really
exciting
i hear you on that and you've steered
clear from adaptations for most of your
career what made you change your mind
about this one
well netflix has that option you know i
can make it six episodes i can make it
at eight episodes i can make it four
episodes it doesn't be crammed into the
hour and a half and so this is eight
episodes you'll watch it hopefully in
one sitting as my hope um and it just is
better for the binge and the novel i
think having that sort of streaming
service where people you know don't
start at 10 or 11 o'clock at night i
promise you you'll be up to four or five
in the morning which is really my hope
but so i think netflix gives you that
and i think we can do that with stay
close
well that's the thing harlan because
this is plot twist on top a plot twist
on top of plot twist i plan to just
watch a couple of episodes and then by
then i was hooked so i was one of those
people that stayed up very late and even
until the very end you still keep us
guessing what is your process in trying
to keep the audience on the edge because
the the the tv show the series ends very
different than the book
yeah well i wanted to throw one more
surprise at the people who read the book
and were smugly watching all eight
episodes saying oh i know how it's going
to end so i throw one we throw one
i was actually on the show with you uh
gail we talked about this book a number
of years definitely me i figured it out
i love surprising
but i've heard you say and then you
didn't figure it out no i didn't figure
this one out at all i've heard you say
that you always start with an idea not a
character when you write a book what was
your idea behind this one because all of
the four characters all the characters
are so interesting have great
backstories what was your idea
four lives blown up 17 years ago by an
event and now they all have to come
together and figure it out to get
redemption and and to move on with their
lives all keeping some sort of secret
that will explode in just ways you won't
expect
you know i want to stay close is bonkers
fun i hope i i mean yeah it's just a
show that you can just sit back and
enjoy
bonkers it is bonkers fine it wasn't
bonkers fun to have your daughter
involved in the production of this she
wrote a few episodes uh she's a producer
on it you're the executive producer or
one of the executive producers so how
did you draw the line between being dad
and being a colleague
well we fought a lot of course in
healthy ways she's much better with the
humor and the young people stuff there's
a part not to give anything away but
using a fingernail polish
that i had no idea existed and a lot of
people are asking me about it now that's
something she came up with a lot of the
most of the funny lines between um
fester and ray she came up with so she's
been a real asset especially in terms of
of
coming from a different direction um so
it's been it's been great having
charlotte on it's you know your father
so you try to stay away that's what i
can tell you yeah that fingernail thing
was it was interesting i actually
googled it to see if that was true and
it was true so go charlotte thank you
charlotte was interesting young people
stuff is an extremely father thing to
say no doubt yes young people stuff
harlan coleman we appreciate you thank
you so much for joining us hopefully
next time we talk you can be in studio
yeah please stay close is available now
miss you guys netflix